[MARCHING BAND]
All right, Bobby, I'm
so glad you're here today.
I want you to take a
look at this setup.
We're so excited at what's
going on with homecoming.
This is an effort
that requires probably
nine months to put together.
I believe it.
We've got students, we've
got alumni volunteers,
and we've got staff
that make this happen.
And probably at some point
this afternoon, we'll
have upwards of 50,000
people on the mall,
and it's going to be a
very exciting afternoon.
Hopefully they all go in the
stadium so we fill the stadium.
I hope so!
It's going to be important.
Because it's open
season, for one night,
on duck hunting tonight.
Absolutely.
So I think it's
going to be good.
We've got a parade that
we rode in last year.
It's my second homecoming.
MELINDA BURKE: That's right.
You're an hold hand at this now.
I hit my stride,
and I'm really
loving the spirit of
everyone coming back.
At the alumni
luncheon yesterday,
where you presented me with a
check from the class of 1968--
which was a great
year, great music.
Great music.
Great things happening on--
That's right.
--university campuses
all over the country.
And then the alumna
of the year--
I felt so inadequate and so
humble by sitting in the room
and hearing what all of
our great former students
are doing out in the world.
So you should be happy.
It is amazing,
the kind of impact
our alumni are
making in the world.
ROBERT C. ROBBINS: And what
about the alumni network?
You've done an incredible
job, for the last year,
of getting the alumni
network ready to go.
We are getting a virtual
alumni community ready to go.
In January of 2019, we'll
be launching the Bear Down
Network, which will be
an alumni community that
will allow alumni around
the globe to connect,
with a business directory,
a mentoring platform, job
opportunities.
It will put networking
at our alumni fingertips.
But I'm not an alum.
Could I get in some special way?
You can.
We are not going
to keep you out.
Not by any means.
In fact, if you're an alum,
you can be part of the network.
But also, if you're a parent,
a student, or a donor,
a friend of the
University of Arizona.
So it's going to be a
very vibrant community.
I love it.
[MARCHING BAND]
Getting the
pipeline of students
ready to come to the U of
A today is so important,
and will be for the future.
But I think we've got
to start at your age.
We want you to be
a future wildcat
and be thinking about
what you want to do.
I'm going to do that.
ROBERT C. ROBBINS: What do you
want to do when you grow up?
I want to be a singer, an
animal helper, a TV host--
I think this is
the place for you,
because we can get you ready.
Yay!
ROBERT C. ROBBINS: Yes.
Why don't you look and
tell them, Bear Down?
Bear down!
There we go.
All right.
(ALL) Bear Down!
Go cats!
[MARCHING BAND]